yeah i mean it's it's terrifying quick
before you go
what is the anthrax story from 2001
because i remember that
i remember how absurd it is and i want
you to just go into that just while i
have you here
what is the anthrax story because i
remember how absurd
and ridiculous that was they all pinned
it on one guy and
yeah wow so uh that's not an easy
that's not a quick thing to answer and
it's actually really important uh to go
over it so um
give me a little bit here because one of
the things we've been hearing a buzzword
we've been hearing a lot lately
is dark winter right right it's going to
be a dark winter darkest winter and all
of that
well in june 2001 there was a bio terror
simulation
by what is now the johns hopkins center
for health security which also did event
201 last year
and things like that and it was called
dark winter and it included former cia
directors former fbi directors
and a lot of other prominent national
security officials
and predicted a lot of things that would
later come to take place just a couple
months later during the anthrax attacks
including anthrax being sent
through the mail that anthrax letters
would be received by members of the
media
and also the initial narrative of the
bio terror attack itself which was that
saddam hussein was working with al qaeda
to enact bio terror a bio terror attack
on the u.s this was all gamed out in
june 2001 and then the anthrax attacks
are revealed to the public in october
2001
and that was the initial narrative that
it was gonna that it was uh
anthrax from iraq um and that al qaeda
had been involved in
in all of this stuff uh of course it
later was revealed that the anthrax used
in the attacks was a a strain
exclusive to the us military and had to
have come from either a u.s military lab
or a u.s military contractor so the
whole narrative that it must have been
iraq and al-qaeda eventually started to
fall apart
but a lot of people that had been
involved in dark winter uh tried to run
with that narrative for as long as
possible and what's also important
is that in the period between september
11th and when the anthrax attacks
actually took place
a lot of these people that had been
involved in dark winter like jerome
howard for example
uh had a apparent foreknowledge that
anthrax was going to take place so you
have for example
um jerome howard on the day of 9 11
telling people that they need to start
taking uh
an antibiotic to prevent anthrax
infection this was going on at dick
cheney's office
uh in in particular and then just a
couple days after 9 11 dick cheney was
personally briefed
by the people that created the dark
winter exercise about dark winter
um and all of this stuff and then you
have a bunch of the project for a new
american century think tank neocons
of which dick cheney and donald rumsfeld
were members going on national media
saying anthrax
talking about anthrax constantly you
also had a member of the media that was
at dark winter
judith miller uh being involved in
writing several articles
uh between september 11th and when the
anthrax attacks took place talking about
how
uh talking about anthrax and bioterror
al qaeda and anthrax and all of this
stuff
sort of seeding this narrative and those
attacks end up uh
taking place and um what's really crazy
too
about anthrax is the fbi investigation
itself which was called amerithrax
it took them almost a decade to
officially close that case it's been he
it was hugely
criticized not just by people at the
national academy of sciences
but also by one of the lead
investigators of the investigation for
the fbi itself their lead investigator
richard lambert
actually ended up filing a whistleblower
lawsuit saying that the fbi's
investigation into the anthrax attacks
was a giant cover-up
and that's from the guy that was
investigating it for the fbi itself
but they pinned it on bruce ivins before
they could take it to trial bruce sivans
committed suicide
even though he was under 24 7 fbi
surveillance
and so they didn't actually have to
prove their case against him in court
because he uh conveniently dies right
before they take it to trial
and you know really i would argue the
anthrax
attacks remain unsolved but if you
actually look into some of the
companies that stood to benefit most
from anthrax and what they were doing at
the time it's very
revealing about some possible motives
and that is very alarming and i don't
know if you want me to go into this
time but the company that uh
gained the most from the anthrax attacks
uh which was called bioport at the time
they're now called emergent bio
solutions they're actually
manufacturing the kova 19 vaccine for
operation warp speed
fun yeah so these anthrax attacks
could be they could have been just like
a false flag to like
let's get us into iraq quicker
let's start tying the narratives mass
destruction
thing right had the big event of 911 but
then it was a lot of the anthrax fear
that uh conditioned people to think oh
the uh
terrorism is gonna be a way of life yeah
bioterrorism yeah it wasn't enough 911
we needed the bioterrorism angle i
remember
time magazine the the sarin gas
you know the the japan the photos like
they were really pushing that narrative
hard
and the anthrax right and a lot of very
prominent people involved
uh with the cover-up of the anthrax
attacks and in
very uh shady positions in the lead up
to those attacks are also very
involved in covid19 response right now
right
one of them is the guy that uh was also
very intimately involved in the dark
winter exercise his name is robert
cadlick
he's currently the assistant secretary
for preparedness and response at hhs and
managing covet 19 response
on behalf of hhs and he's the guy that
gave the covet 19 vaccine a complete
liability anyone that administers or
manufactures that vaccine can't be
liable
in emergent biosolutions the company i
mentioned earlier he used to be a
lobbyist for them
and has been just involved in a lot of
really crazy stuff over the
the past couple years basically um you
know huge conflicts of interest with
that particular
company which has very shady ties to the
2001 anthrax attacks
how is the country that you're in doing
with covet 19
oh it's a mess well i mean chile is a
u.s client state so i mean it's
basically following a similar uh
playbook but it's
it's a lot more draconian than even
what's going on in the us and that's
because after the
um 1973 coup um
backed by the cia and henry kissinger
that installed pinochet
the pinochet dictatorship in chile it's
basically been used as a laboratory
by the u.s power structure for different
things whether it's neoliberalism for
example was essentially
born in chile they say because they use
it as a giant laboratory for that
but also i would argue some of the more
draconian equivalent 19 responses uh
that we may see in the next couple of
weeks in different states in the us
um you know had they been piloting some
of that out here so
since march for example there's been
curfews in chile
they have a five-phase uh lockdown
system where they constantly move
uh cities back into lockdown uh based on
you know faulty data i would argue
because the
the minister of health admitted that he
was making up numbers uh not that long
ago
uh after he resigned he was pretty
blatant about it because you know
uh there's no accountability really in
chile like the us but i would argue
would you ever would you ever come back
to america to get assassinated
um i'd have to think about it i don't
know i mean i have a toddler too so i
mean just even the idea of getting on a
plane with a
a little kid and have to make her wear a
mask the whole time for an overnight
flight i
doesn't really it's appealing but you
got to go on a book tour if you finish
epstein book you got to go on a book
tour
well if america still left i'll think
about it we'll see
if if america's not left i don't think
chile will be left either